It means a lot.
It definitely means a lot.
Um,
because
I think there were so many people
who doubted that it would actually
happen.
There are so many people who said get,
that's cool,
but it's not going to happen or he's
gonna get assassinated.
Or,
I mean,
I was watching the Nike Aeration and
watching him getting sworn in.
I was like,
as there's going to be the shot now,
like I was so scared.
And so it meant so much,
I think to our generation and I'm
coining our generation generation.
Why not?
Because I think that he exemplified all
the possibilities of what you can do if
you just believe and try hard enough.
He is the most
relevant.
How ratio augers story that we have had
in this country in a long time.
And you know,
for young people,
especially young people of color,
who
didn't think that that was possible,
that meant a lot.
And I think that that motivated so many
of us,
and there's a series of events that have
motivated our generation to be one of
the greatest generations since the great
depression generation.
I like one of those was hurricane
Katrina,
one of those was having a Dick in the
Office for eight years who hung out with
a Bush.
Um,
and then
after that it was getting to that point
of so much frustration that the audacity
that we actually had the audacity to go
outside of our box and elect a young
African American president.
And that is what's redefining our
generation.
And not only just the economic
situation,
but I think that
we were so complacent during Bush's
term.
We were so overwhelmed by how ridiculous
it was that we didn't feel like we can
do anything about it.
And Obama's when shows that we can,
if we put our minds to it.
And
I think that's what it meant to me the
most,
is that it was very motivating of my own
personal.